hi my name is Cara Delevingne and I'm
going undercover on the Internet
this is actually me ready am I ready are
you ready okay let's go let's start with
Twitter do you think Heidi will be a
good wrestler yes I will whoop your ass
so good luck I'm not inviting anyone to
try and do that though I think they're
dangerous but seriously don't try is it
hard to imitate an American accent
I'd love to do accents my whole life I
love music I love to imitate people to
annoy them so and enter YouTube that is
actually me if Instagram was a person
what would you say to her sash him why
can't I show my nipples on you weird
can we clone her so we can all enjoy
life a little more
sure I'm into clothing
I would like to clone many things me
maybe not so much I don't think that
would be good for the world though what
could be fun an abundance of the year so
go ahead she has the word bacon tattooed
on the bottom of her thirds they do I'm
not so sure how into it I am anymore
just because I'm trying to eat meat less
but it was a time in my life and I don't
regret it I'm gonna maybe put pharmacist
bacon in front of it because I think
he's great
Yahoo lance's how do I get card out of
his eyebrow game you know what game that
is but basically you just let them beast
grow maybe give him a rub occasionally
you get those follicles as you think and
don't really talk to them unless I
wouldn't tell skew to yeah let the
beatified and submit how to be that card
out of a I'm 16 and a guy and me and car
had the same birthday and sick star star
star eyebrows how
people like her I love us so much I
don't know your name but I'm sure you're
thankful to and be yourself that's what
I have to say and I hope one day I get
to meet you stroke your eyebrows you can
stroke each other's / be nice I love a
good stroke all that sounds strange okay
officially on the Internet's I am DB
trademarks bubbly personality eyebrows
likes to photobomb at events yes I felt
like I was the originator of the
photobomb I wasn't ready okay
a force trademark I'd like to add I like
to play Scrabble and boggle and I like
to sing in the shower especially posted
reddit what is that me it looks like a
very pretty Norwegian girl that doesn't
like me though but it's amazing
sometimes like if do you put me and like
someone else together thank you whoever
drew this unico it's an immense
incredible I can't leave that's pencil
Wow anyone know where to get that dress
oh my god my butt cheeks are in that
photo
hi little red panties um I think it was
DJ why answers.com that is actually me
one second
how is Cara Delevingne discovered I did
my first photo shoot when I was about 8
years old I think it was a big Bruce
Weber for Italian Vogue it was really
random I don't know how it happened
my mother just picked up some sports day
interview to a hat shop how tall is
quite at I mean I am 5 foot 8 know what
that is and centimeters more yahoo
answers which football camp is acquired
a levine support i've always when she's
a tomboy that she likes to play football
I was wondering which football club she
supports yes I'm a Chelsea fan if she
were it would be amazing I am a Chelsea
fan I've supported chastity since I was
a kid
mastered Zola fans to go to the games a
lot not so much anymore
but we'll always be a fan of the blue
Instagram Wow music what is that called
again
yep can you tell us more it does okay
wow that's a cool tattoo why does it say
[ __ ] I mean I like it
cool fiction baby Wow where'd you find
these
I've never actually met anyone with my
face tattooed on their I'm gonna skank
but if I did I would maybe think about
getting their face on my skin maybe it's
not a college but I'll question it sent
that's a beautiful drawing I don't even
know what picture that is it's very cool
I'm so honored to all these people draw
me an amazing artist why am I still
talking in American accent sorry
instincts submit Oh Cora it's not really
nice Velma car says that when she was a
model that walk she would walk like
she's had loads of sex is this good
advice for models or simply a
provocative comment honestly it was
because when I first started walking I
walked like I had a stick up my butt so
it was about removing that stick and
just like feeling it I think that's what
I read by having sex
honestly don't isn't are things I say
scent and now you know a little bit more
about me done and dusted
so here